please welcome the Dean of the School of
Professional Studies at Columbia
University dr. jason wyngarde
[Applause]
thank you very much and good afternoon
it is my pleasure to officially welcome
the class of 2017 degree candidates
family friends faculty members executive
vice president dr. David Madigan dean
emeritus dr. Frank wolf and
distinguished guests to the graduation
ceremony for the School of Professional
Studies for those of you who took my
course on organizational strategy this
year you know that I mercilessly made
you practice elevator pitches now for
those of you who don't know what
elevator pitches are it's a very short
period of time basically the length of
an elevator ride when you are able to
clearly articulate a proposal or clearly
represent yourself so I thought it would
be impactful today to use this occasion
to randomly call on one of our degree
candidates bring you to the stage put
you in my elevator and test you in front
of all of our distinguished guests and
family members I have my list of names
here but fortunately for you all today
my staff said I didn't have enough time
to do this exercise but I hope you would
have been ready instead I'll ask you
from your seats what does it mean to be
a graduate of the School of Professional
Studies in 2017 a graduate of SPS the
School of Professional Studies at
Columbia University in the city of New
York are you ready to articulate your
value proposition
are you ready to articulate your
competitive advantage in the global
marketplace you are graduating from the
best school at the best university in
the best city in the world so be
prepared to articulate what that means
for you and what that means for your
position in the world today I have five
recommendations for you this will help
you navigate your future I hope number
one change constantly it is often said
that the only constant is change
to succeed in the ever-changing global
marketplace
you must be adaptive strategic and
flexible strategic mandates change skill
requirements change labor practices
change environmental conditions change
your interests will change embrace this
change be a first mover apply what
you've learned adapt compete and
ultimately win replay that cycle in your
career will float above the chaos of
constant change and disruption number
two learn to succeed not just to cope be
sure that as you move into a new role in
industry or advance in an existing role
that you are steadfastly focused on
getting ahead and not just getting by
too often people go to work but their
full potential doesn't show up barriers
get in the way and then you downshift
from hunter mode to survival mode
prepare yourself for where you want to
be and learn how to get there keep
learning how to get there your time at
SPF here has been an investment in that
approach so refuse to let and be lulled
into complacency number three reinvent
yourself your new masters degree
provides you with an updated profile but
what's next
for some of you it's a promotion for
others it's a new job but for all of you
it should be a process of new learning
so know that learning doesn't stop and
it shouldn't stop broadening your base
of knowledge sharpen the tools in your
box and relentlessly seek ways to
further develop don't just learn for now
but learn for life you see the theme as
the global knowledge economy continues
to evolve so should you
number four of five be excellent as I
said before you are graduating from the
best school at the best university in
the best city in the world your faculty
program directors family friends and
fellow students understand the hard work
and dedication and commitment it took
for you to accomplish what you have
today now it's time for you to bring
your a-game hold yourself accountable
for recognizing what best-in-class looks
like and then hold yourself accountable
for setting out to achieve it yourself
and number five engage Columbia for
better or worse and I think better you
are now part of the SPS family you are
now part of the broader Columbia family
forever and so like a family this
community will always be there when you
need it the colleagues friends and
faculty that you've worked with studied
with or heard lectures from will serve
as your support and your support network
it will be foolish of you not to
leverage your family to advance your
goals so use this use your cohort and
use Columbia if you do I promise that
navigating your professional path will
be substantially easier so in conclusion
I ask you again what's your elevator
pitch what does it mean to be a graduate
of SPS the School of Professional
Studies at Columbia University in the
city of New York it means that you were
selected competitively from a pool of
the finest highest caliber applicants in
the world you got in when most did not
it
you completed yes it also means you
completed successfully an
interdisciplinary academic curriculum
that was customized pedagogically
rigorous and market applicable the work
was hard and intense but you got it done
and it means finally that you have now
specialized skills and support network
to compete and succeed in the global
marketplace you are now ready for the
job of the future and we are proud of
you it is now my distinct pleasure to
introduce executive vice president and
dean of the Faculty of Arts and Sciences
and professor of statistics dr. David
Madigan
executive vice president Madigan joined
Columbia's faculty in 2007 as a
professor of statistics and became the
department's chair the following year
prior to joining Columbia executive vice
president Madigan was Dean of physical
and mathematical sciences at Rutgers
University
he has also previously held positions at
AT&T soliloquy the University of
Washington and SkillSoft
during his distinguished academic career
executive vice president Madigan
received countless academic accolades he
has authored over 120 publications and
is an elected fellow of the American
Statistical Association the institution
of mathematical statistics and the
American Association for the Advancement
of science he recently completed a term
as editor-in-chief of statistical
science and is the current editor of
statistical analysis and data mining the
School of Professional Studies has truly
benefited from his academic leadership
at Columbia
he recognizes and supports the diversity
of the 21st century student population
and specifically values the
contributions of lifelong learners in
the Academy he is supportive of the use
of innovative modalities in the teaching
and learning process for its potential
to enhance pedagogy and he believes in
the critical importance of scholarly
thought and of translating ideas and
learning into solutions that can be
applied in the real world for all these
reasons I'd like to thank executive vice
president David Madigan
for being key to the success of the
School of Professional Studies please
join me in welcoming our executive vice
president dr. David Madigan
a little smaller than Jason actually
before I start this let me let me begin
by thanking Dean jason wyngarde for the
extraordinary job he's doing with this
school
we're very proud of him thank you for
everything you do a warm welcome
a warm Columbia welcome with the Dean to
our outstanding students and faculty and
the cherished cherished parents families
and friends who have joined us today
thank you for being here
graduation is a very significant and
meaningful event for all of us for
students it is an important indication
that you have prepared for the next
steps in your careers for faculty it is
a signal that you have successfully
transferred the knowledge and skills of
our disciplines and our professions to
the next generation of leaders for
family and friends it is an opportunity
to celebrate this important milestone
with your loved ones and for the
university it is the time when we
welcome a group of individuals that have
been united by a school into the wider
Columbia alumni community that spans the
globe I take particular pride in our
School of Professional Studies graduates
because you'll recognize the value of
renewing your knowledge and of
continually investing in your
professional development when Columbia
admitted each one of you it was with
great care and part about what we
believed you could achieve and the
mission of this institution to transform
knowledge and understanding in service
of the greater good as you have studied
at the School of Professional Studies
you have been reinventing yourselves and
your careers and now as you're about to
depart this campus as alumni the cambia
community will be your champion
reminding you throughout your lives that
you can make a mark in the world through
your endeavors we are grateful that you
chose to come to Columbia in pursuit of
your goals and aspirations you have
enriched our academic community and as
alumni I'm sure you will continue and I
hope you will continue to remain
lifelong partners we are proud of
Columbia School of Professional Studies
and us grad
would stay in touch with the friends you
have made here with the professors you
admired most and be sure to leave the
world a better place than you found it
congratulations to all of you thank you
so if you wonder why dr. Madigan's robe
is so colorful and cheery compared to
everyone else's it's because in the
Academy you wear the robe of your
terminal degree so wherever you got your
PhD or your JD that is the road that you
wear so he graduated with his PhD from
Trinity College Dublin and that is why
he has that colorful road thank you
again dr. Madigan it is now my privilege
to introduce to you the 2017 Columbia
University School of Professional
Studies graduation speaker we are
pleased and honored today to welcome mr.
Randall Lane editor of Forbes magazine
Forbes is one of the leading business
publications in the world since its
founding in 1917 Forbes has been a
global media company focusing on
business investing technology
entrepreneurship leadership and
lifestyle Forbes is celebrating its
centennial anniversary this year with
strong numbers mr. Lane has helped the
print magazine reach its highest ever
u.s. readership of 6.8 million highest
print ever with a new emphasis on young
innovators and disruptors the magazine
has seen a 50 percent increase with the
Millennial market of readers ages 18 to
34 online Ford website reaches an
audience of 56 million readers monthly
with 30 million followers on social
media mr. Lane understands the mindset
of innovators and disruptors because he
has been an entrepreneur himself before
assuming his role as editor at Forbes in
2011 Lane spent more than a decade
leading and co-founded media startups
and launched almost a dozen magazines
and related websites he is the author of
you only have to be right once
the unprecedented rise of the instant
tech billionaire he is also the creator
of two of the most significant annual
events of the past decade the Forbes 400
summit on philanthropy and the Forbes
under 30 summit
mr. Lane holds a bachelor's degree from
the University of Pennsylvania as a
journalist at a renowned institution
that is now 100 years old he has had
access to some of the world's most
successful and powerful business leaders
and have studied how individuals can
reimagine the rules of business and use
of interment entrepreneurial mindset to
solve the world's most intractable
problems he understands the mission of
the School of Professional Studies he
understands the power of learning for
life and he understands the need to
embrace possibility please join me in
welcoming our 2017 graduation speaker
mr. Randall Lane
[Applause]
and Thank You Dean winger for that very
kind introduction for everything you do
here thank you to executive vice
president Madigan thank you to the
faculty thank you to the parents and
friends and family no more tuition
checks guys haha and most of all thank
you to the hard-working optimistic and
very good-looking Columbia School of
Professional Studies class of 2017
congratulations
so here we are as Dean winger said at
the graduation for the most innovative
school in the most prestigious
university in the most ambitious city in
the most dynamic country yes still if
you want to think big you want to leave
your mark do you want to impact the
world that makes everyone graduating
today a game-changer you have no choice
really it says so right on your diploma
in Latin now I'm looking at all the
sticklers out there these actuarial
science out there represent so so I'm
looking the stickler than they're saying
well wait you know it actually that's
actually the Columbia motto in Latin
which technically says in nightlights
that's translated if in thy light we
shall see light but I speak a more
modern Latin dialect and the way I
translated you're all actually getting a
master's degree in disruption you're all
actually getting a master's degree in
thinking differently you're all actually
getting a master's degree in making the
world a better place you're all actually
getting a master's degree in the
broadest sense and being woke a master's
degree in change in the world with the
skills to do something about it and
that's all fitting because however you
term it there has never been a better
time in history for those who are young
and smart and ambitious never for the
first two million years that humans
walked the earth there with one
consistent rule the tools you needed to
accomplish great things resources
experiences networks wisdom credibility
that required age that required time
whether you were a blacksmith a ship
builder or a lawyer you need to learn
your
aid save your pennies and wait your turn
but those constant two million years
changed about a decade ago the digital
era has also s assured in the age of no
age where anyone with a great idea can
agree chief great things the barriers
have been removed this is a
revolutionary development revolutionary
become because it flies in the face of
the human experience
revolutionary because it's not just the
tech industry every field is now a text
via whether you're in sports or
sustainability or construction
revolutionary because thinking
differently is now an advantage that
advantage comes because of the way your
brains are wired all of you came of age
with the internet most of you can't even
remember a time when there wasn't an
internet that natural comfort with
pervasive immersive technology gives you
a leg up you look at problems in a
digital first manner and find solutions
innately
that others can't see this tech
savviness alone isn't enough everyone
here is also psychologically up to the
challenge you want to start things you
want to be an entrepreneur whether
for-profit or nonprofit you understand
that entrepreneurship the ability to
create things is now the safe route as
well the route to take if you want to
create change on a massive scale the
biggest risk is not taking a risk I've
seen this in my career every chance I've
taken has led to greater opportunity
every failure I've had has led to
greater success and I see this every day
at Forbes
from our covers to our billionaires
rankings to our 30 under 30 list the
poster child for this age of no age is
Mark Zuckerberg before he was 25 he
changed how the world in her ex but
within the Facebook universe alone there
are others who have done as much or more
to change how we see things
Zuckerberg referred a guy named Kevin
Systrom a job during the early days of
Facebook along with enough stock options
that today that would be worth many tens
of millions of dollars system turned him
down he wanted to do his own thing well
the next time sucker
bergman Systrom system was serving
zuckerberg a cup of coffee at a cafe in
Silicon Valley it's true so it's a
really bad move right
well sistrum had his own idea and app
that allowed people to edit their
pictures and then share them to change
the way we literally see each other you
now know it is Instagram and when he
sold it to Facebook five years later or
five years ago the price was the cool
one billion dollars
system was 28 years old Palmer Luckey
wonder why we all couldn't have an
experience like we have an avatar so he
researched using Google he bought parts
using eBay he crowd-sourced ideas on
hacker forums he raised capital on
Kickstarter eventually cobbled together
the oculus rift headset he created
virtual reality and three years ago he
sold it to Facebook for two billion
dollars he was 21 and then there's young
Coon he was born in the Ukraine and
emigrated there as a teenager his father
died back there his mother got cancer
here they lived on welfare checks and
then she died - John Coon was an orphan
in a strange land a high school dropout
with choppy English what happened next
speaks to the opportunities you all have
yan kuma smart and he was tech savvy he
got a job at Yahoo he saved his money
and then inspiration struck he built an
app that would automatically tell your
contact list where you were all the time
the only problem no one wants everyone
on their contact list to know where they
are all the time I think you guys would
actually pay not to have that app on
your phone but he also noticed that most
people were using his dimension to
message each other now you and I am more
than 1 billion users know his service as
whatsapp for the first time any two
people in the world could text each
other for free so three years ago the 38
year old immigrant sold was whatsapp to
Facebook for wait for it 22 billion
dollars
and he signed the contract in front of
the welfare office where you used to
collect this checks the American Dream
built on innovation and opportunity is
alive and well and all of us no matter
our age no matter our background now
have a chance to realize it all you need
is an idea now I know we have some of
the greatest nonprofit management
graduates in the world today nonprofit
management you out there all right for
social entrepreneurs those same skills
apply let me tell you about three
nonprofits that I work with the first of
the group called last mile health served
by an amazing man named Raj Punjabi Raj
was born to Indian parent parents in the
India in the African country of Liberia
they fled the Civil War there and
immigrated to America where Raj went to
middle school he became a doctor and he
joined the faculty of Harvard Medical
School but he never forgot where he came
from one of the 10 poorest countries in
the world where just 51 doctors served
the country of 4 million people think
about that
51 doctors in an entire country even a
minor ailment in a remote village with a
death sentence so when he was in his 20s
he created a new healthcare model rather
than fruitlessly try to get doctors to
move to Liberia he trained a local in
each village to handle the most basic
needs and he cut the premature death
rate in Liberia by 90%
last month he won the skull prize in the
TED Prize to the highest honors in
social entrepreneurship the second is
also in Liberia a school called more
than me it was founded by a woman from
New Jersey in her 20s named Katie miler
she saw the girls there had no safe
place to learn and thus no hope
so rather than start a regular school
she made her Academy comprehensive
taking the girls in feeding and housing
them giving them psychological
counseling and a place to call home
she's reforming now she's now reforming
the entire country school system and
when the Ebola crisis hit Katie stayed
she had already built a network that
could mobilize unless she saved
thousands of lives and for this she was
named one a Time magazine
persons of the year the third of the
organization called global citizens
third by 25 year old Australian Hugh
Evans the mission is simple in extreme
poverty by 2030 the model turns anyone
into an activist to the point system
that rewards action with concert tickets
and the results are remarkable more than
10 million actions taken have resulted
in more than 30 billion dollars in
government commitments to end extreme
poverty so what do all these three
people have in common well first just
like chemistry strim and Palmer Luckey
and young Combe they are using the
practical skill sets that you all have
learned numeracy reason thinking tech
savviness to create new models to attack
societal problems second they're all
immigrants Raj and Hugh immigrated to
this country and Katy emigrated from
this country the entire world is now
connected and you can scale your dreams
on a global basis and third that came
from humble backgrounds all of them men
were born rich or even muddled upper
middle class they succeeded on merits
the bottom line there's nothing holding
any of you back you have your education
your suite of knowledge you have your
Ivy League degree your credential and
most important you have new ideas and a
world that needs them and doesn't
discriminate based on wit where or who
those ideas come from I can't wait to
see what you all accomplished in the
decades ahead and I'm sure I'll see
several of you on the page of the Forbes
staring back at me because of something
you did to make the world a better place
so in that way I look forward to
crossing paths with each of you again
thank you for everything you do and are
going to do congratulations
now go change the world
Thank You Randall for your inspiring
words and stories now for the deans
Excellence Awards the deans excellence
award is the highest honor that the
School of Professional Studies bestowed
and is given to those who consistently
adeptly and passionately serve the
mission of the school as well as those
who exemplify at the highest levels the
attributes of academic scholarly and
professional excellence
the recipients are chosen through a
rigorous nomination and evaluation
process led by our Dean's excellence
selection committee today we will grant
for the Dean's Excellence Awards in the
categories of student faculty alumni and
administrator this year student
recipient of the deans excellent board
is Steven James kppen Edith
[Applause]
James is graduating with a Master of
Science degree in sports management with
an impressive GPA of 4.11
[Applause]
raised in Melbourne Australia James
earned a Bachelor of Science from the
University of Melbourne in 2012 between
2009 and 2014 he also volunteered as a
coach in the Victorian junior basketball
league in late 2014 James decided to
pursue his passion in the sports
business and by fall 2015 had joined the
Columbia community in his first semester
he secured a year-long internship with
our sports management operations and
career services department by his final
semester James was integral to a student
team that won the inaugural Columbia
University basketball analytics Case
Competition
James now works in his dream job as an
analyst at Madison Square Garden in
pricing and inventory optimization he
remains committed to Columbia having
returned in a teaching capacity twice
over this past year to facilitate the
courses sports revenue strategies and
analytics and sports accounting and
finance please join me in recognizing
with the Dean's Excellence Award for a
student student Steven James cope and
Edith
[Applause]
this year's faculty recipient of the
deans excellent award is dr. Lynette
Witter dr. Witter is a faculty member in
the sustainability management program
[Applause]
she received a PhD in the history and
theory of architecture from ETH Zurich a
master's in architecture from Columbia
University and a Bachelor of Arts from
Barnard College dr. Witter has 15 years
of experience teaching design to
students and previously served as
associate professor and head of the
department of architecture at the Rhode
Island School of Design she is a very
active in Columbia in our school and in
the sustainability management admissions
process serving on numerous committees
including the Schools Committee on
instruction dr. Witter has presented her
scholarly research nationally and
internationally in the professional
community she is highly regarded and
serves as principal and co-founder of
aardvark in texture a small architecture
practice that specializes in residential
work this June and exhibition curated by
dr. Witter will open at the AIA
New York Center for architecture her
commitment to teaching scholarship
practitioner achievements and the School
of Professional Studies is exceptional
please join me in recognizing with the
Dean's excellent award for faculty dr.
Lynette Witter
[Applause]
this year's alumni recipient of the
deans Excellence Award is Claudia Lam
Claudia is a 2010 alumna of the
technology management program in
addition to holding a Bachelor of
Science in electrical engineering from
New York University and having earned a
project management certificate from
Stanford University she is fluent in
Mandarin and Cantonese
Claudia currently serves as program
manager at Space Systems Loral Claudia
is not only a skilled technical expert
but also a visionary thinker with years
of experience building successful teams
as well as having success in driving it
in small groups and established
companies since graduating from our
school she has remained engaged as an
ambassador a School of Professional
Studies course instructor a mentor and a
programming partner please join me in
recognizing with the Dean's Excellence
Award for alumni
Claudia Lam
[Applause]
and finally this year's administrator
recipient of the deans excellent award
for Dean's accent award is Dominique
Studer as a program advisor Dominique
took on a direct student support role
helping our sports management and
construction administration students
achieve their educational goals
Dominique recently accepted more
responsibility as an assistant director
for student lifestyle cycle support
again supporting our students she
approaches her role with an infectious
sense of curiosity and actively seeks
new ways to improve the student
experience Dominique has also been an
unofficial mentor to colleagues and
teammates some of you may have had an
opportunity to work with Dominique and
we are fortunate at the school to have
people so committed to serving our
community please join me in recognizing
with the 2017 deans Excellence Award for
an administrator Dominique scooter
I would now like to take the opportunity
to ask the chair of the Columbia Alumni
Association Brian Chris Berg to join me
on stage to recognize another
outstanding member of our school
community with the Campbell Award the
Campbell Award is presented in
collaboration with the Columbia Alumni
Association to a graduating student who
shows exceptional leadership and
Columbia spirit as exemplified by a
distinguished alumnus the late Bill
Campbell Bill Campbell was a class of
1962 graduate of Columbia College where
he played on the football team and a
class of 1964 graduate of Teachers
College he served as Columbia's football
coach from 1974 to 1979 as chair of the
Columbia University Board of Trustees
from 2005 to 2015 and was co-founder of
the Columbia Alumni Association the
Campbell Award is selected by the
Columbia Alumni Association prizes and
awards committee and special
consideration was given this year to
student leaders who have demonstrated a
willingness and ability to work across
schools the winner of this year's
Campbell Award for the School of
Professional Studies is Ryan Monell
[Applause]
brian is a member of this year's
graduating class with a Master of
Science in strategic communication brian
typifies the type of leader that the
Campbell award was created to recognize
internally Ryan was known as STS Thomas
Jefferson while holding a full-time job
which we all know is challenging he was
also instrumental in the launch of the
first school-wide student government
organization at SPS negotiating
tirelessly with individuals and groups
across the university to create an
association that would enhance the SPS
student experience he was a committed
and effective SPS student senator for
the past year and he was a wonderful
event partner to Brian Chris Berg and
the Student Alumni Association please
join me on behalf of the School of
Professional Studies and the Columbia
Alumni Association in congratulating
Brian Monell as the recipient of the
2017 Campbell Award
[Applause]
let's give it a hand again to
congratulate the winners at this time it
is my pleasure to introduce our 2017
student graduation speaker dominant
Rinaldi
[Applause]
Dominic is a popular student Dominic is
a graduate of the Master of Science
program in negotiation and conflict
resolution
prior to matriculating to Columbia
Dominic received a Bachelor of Arts
degree in psychology with a minor in
women's and gender studies from Wilkes
University while it wilkes he
volunteered as a bystander intervention
peer trainer where he provided lectures
to peers and faculty to help prevent
instances of sexual violence within the
campus community during that time
dominic also accepted a full-time
internship at the Pennsylvania Attorney
General's Bureau of Consumer Protection
where he was first exposed to mediation
in the organizational setting after
moving to New York City to study
full-time at the School of Professional
Studies he found another full-time
internship at the United Nations
Ombudsman and mediation services over
the last two years
Dominic has distinguished himself as a
leader within our school community he
has served as the secretary for the
Association of negotiation and conflict
resolution students a negotiation
conflict resolution program
representative and as vice president for
the school Professional Studies Student
Association now that he is armed with a
master's degree Dominic Dominic tells me
that his aspirations are to become an
organizational Ombudsman and mediator
ideally at an institution of higher
education
maybe Columbia Dominic lives by one
motto be a peace of peace he was
nominated I'll let you think about that
for a second be a peace of peace he was
nominated to be this year's graduation
speaker winning this honor demonstrates
the respect that our faculty student
body and staff have for Dominic
his nomination also highlights his
success as a student and as a
professional and his potential to tackle
challenges great and small through the
study of negotiation and conflict
resolution please join me in welcoming
this year's student speaker dominant
Renauld Thank You Dean GREENGUARD and
thank you everyone who is here today I
appreciate it
well colleagues and friends it's a
beautiful day to graduate I remember the
first day I visited this campus it was a
very cold February 19th that comes to
attend an informational session for my
graduate program in negotiation and
conflict resolution we're commonly known
as NEC our iris I recall walking into
Lowe library hoping to get to talk to
the program director that's Fisher
Yoshida of course I was nervous at the
tail end of my undergraduate career
Columbia was at the top of my long list
of graduate schools I had applied too
soon I had my moment with Beth and I'd
be granted pour out all of my interests
she stopped me with one question she
said what makes this program better fit
for you than any other program you've
applied to well I can't recall what my
exact answer was I do recall but I felt
that NEC art program would provide an
opportunity to continue studying
something I was greatly passionate about
in the midst of graduation I've recently
been revisiting this question did you
find what you were looking for when you
first applied to the school Professional
Studies within the first year of
studying conflict resolution I learned
that some of the better qualities of a
professional in this field is being able
to see different perspectives to
empathize with a differing narrative
than your own I began to see the
importance in taking time to listening
attentively to reflect on what I was
hearing and to separate interests from
positions as a result when I stepped
outside of the classroom I was more open
to stories that were much different than
my own
I saw myself paying more attention to
others actions and the underlying
meaning in their work
it was like I had tapped into this whole
new level of communication with others
however I soon started to see that there
was a challenge to this as well it's
plain to see that there's been a growing
contention within this nation over the
last year or so being how diverse New
York City is everywhere I've gone with
almost every person that I've interacted
with I've heard polarizing stories that
bear the weight of fear helplessness
disdain and even contempt eventually the
power of these stories had begun to
overwhelming as if the weight from them
was resting on my shoulders
growing heavier by the day that little
voice you know the one that makes you
second-guess yourself said to me Dominic
how are you going to ensure a happy
ending to every story I began to
question the capability I had as a
person the aims to make a living out of
resolving conflict however my doubts and
myself began to change as it continued
this program through the teachings of my
influential professors and colleagues I
began to see that the value that I have
doesn't come from controlling the
outcomes it comes from dedicating time
to the process and to those who share
their stories with me my value is being
a resource a trusted safe haven a person
who will work with you to explore
options so that you can rewrite your
story so that it has the ending that you
seek with this realization I became even
more motivated as a student studying at
SPS I took on an internship with the
United Nations Ombudsman and mediation
services where I would be able to gain
more skills on how to be a resource for
those within a complex organization
additionally I became an SDS Student
Association representative as well as
the secretary for the Association for
conflict resolution students where I
would be able to have the privilege to
utilize my conflict resolution skills
even further to be a voice for my peers
and create fun engaging events for us to
come together and talk about those
relevant topics in our current time and
finally I'm able to stand up here today
as your current student speaker I did
find what I was looking for when I
applied to the school Professional
Studies this school and all of those
within it have inspired me and fostered
my passion what I didn't expect when I
first applied was how coming here would
enable me to
the conflict within myself and then
through community rise above it so that
one day I could be able to be the person
that perhaps all of you could turn to
when it conflict arises so in my last
words I aim to encourage you for your
next steps into the future we are now
the thought leaders and innovators of
our fields and professions each and
every one of us has something even more
to offer utilize what you came here to
experience at ICS put it as part of your
value leverage it make it currency and
never forget how much value you have
thank you SDS in class of 2017
for all you've taught me I have never
felt so close to community people as I
do today I'm looking forward to seeing
the amazing thing as you guys will do
thank you
thank you again Dominic for your
uplifting words and your leadership we
will now ask Andy assert associate dean
of program dr. Eric Nelson associate
dean of academic affairs and dr. Tatum
Stu Kim associate dean of Student
Affairs to name the candidates for
degree our esteem program directors will
join them at the podium and congratulate
their programs graduates we will also be
joined by Maryland Cohn associate dean
of institutional advancement who will
ceremonially welcome our graduates into
the Alumni community with the School
Professional Studies alumni pin as they
exit the stage we will begin with andy
andy answered associate dean of programs
thank you dean winGuard action royal
science will a candidate for the Master
of Science degree in actuarial science
please proceed to the stage we'd also
like to welcome the program director dr.
Lena Xue to congratulate the graduates
: Fang Zhi Jing Chang Jung Jin where
Jang Kelly Matthews Asia Pillai
suetilley Blatche leaming Jen Jung Jin
Jia young song human song raiding Chang
wen hoo-ha
when longhand man ching way you lose ow
Dean one evening one GE turn Ryan
Nicholas thank you whenever a Brahma
Vova carloon who on duty are young
Jionni Stella Jim Hong is you Carson in
oh yeah
ginger chew Jehan Jia Ming Juan shinning
Wan Xiu Zhao see Tony June where two
people died young
Vince and I met Ameen Hyundai ha - no
glue
Marco's Clara's official Malik Malik
Hernandez aru Christina Bob Angela
[Music]
autumn Kim and tong li yachty Suhani
sharma one Lin Chen we look
Adam Leventhal yes Alexander walls you
and Lee Clark young chuncho brian jay
chou a applied analytics will the
candidates for the Master of Science
degree in applied analytic please
proceed to the stage we would also like
to welcome the program director Thomas D
Lee to congratulate the graduates thank
you Leora her town Chi Valliere
Sebastian kisara
sorry about that I know I messed that
one up alessandro longer Mario Salinas
Mario's Rodrigo Prado Randy Mario chana
Zi Jun John Boehner on foo Edgar
Richmond
Jamie Larry Oh banaba Kieran kirker
Tiffany Fung your chantin a lethally
eun-hyung way should you
Jinyoung Wang did just want yes hyung
woo on Steen Menger Tanya Lee Truman law
eun-hwan John King John Chiang Yahoo Leo
TT Chang you go Fuu Jin Lee Jung get on
move
Natasha Jones eternity Chung D tau sorry
Han yung shue Wing Chun datum Jung Jung
Hwan Iran ciao
Jung soo young
Jing Lang there in Bai Zhi Sheng Wang
Sen Tian
yes Bao GU yalla lu c chili
yeah Juancho shadaloo you ciao
Thank You Joey Jesse Liang Hanako you to
Chen Chelsea and sour for new shake run
Wong who on leo
Rayo young weighed on chu-young Lee
sorry Oman sullivo Diaz Ming John Jay
King who Jay juegue when he hung when be
on scene Oh
young young long Sookie Chen Daniel you
Joon young young Nima
will the candidates for the Master of
Science degree in bioethics please
proceed to the stage we'd also like to
welcome the program director Deborah
Robert Crissman to congratulate the
graduates hi Bob thank you
Samir Hyder Ali la da Rafael rollin
Santos Sarah
Kiska Dean Victor Solis de Rojas
Carolyn Stevens
m'lila BCR Mara heater Haider
[Music]
Priscilla Hamilton will the candidates
for the Master of Science degree in
communications practice please proceed
to the stage we would also like to
welcome the program director al-a'raf
Pollack to grand elite the graduates
see de hooch said ah Bora Kim knew
Rebecca I jolly called Thomas drew Tania
silver Karen Silva Kirsten Scott Maya
man Guinea young Maria Paula marchantia
Braille Kathleen low charissa Daniel
Abbas thank you ttyn Appa potion Adana
Miriam Kalon Terry ELISA
Covello Andrea a fool forma Nina oh ha
ha
Oh Hakone Catalonia Diaz granado's needa
shall be Mira
[Applause]
Nisha Tariq sorry show you one Lin Chi
Rebecca prowler
Matilda closer faso patrick you can
oprea mandora amber burton corrida
a consetta z knees are here
Melissa burrito will the candidates for
master of strategic master Science
degree in strategic communication to
proceed priests proceed to the stage and
Arabella I stay here
Alan McNamara
Sosa's con yet Otto Estrada Aaron must
Mahaney Laura Bernstein
Stephen the deal jazmyne coning sofa
need picado Alice Ryan Jordana Waxman
Kelly Chris Rachel Zukerman Peter Beard
Jeffrey Allen Brandi Dawson Elaine Revis
Co valdahon Tatiana Hoff salon big car
Sonam Julie ball mere Amanda to tara
lynn Douglas Morgan McCray Michael Peres
Giselle Monroe
Elizabeth Alicia Williams Lisa nor a
Bonita cockta Odessa Hines
youngji Stella Kelly laughing Anthony
concepcin so Hal Salman what happened
Justin Myers Claire Hopkins Emily so
claw
the Lala scene Stein well Haven grace
hello Ryan Monell interesting I don't
see it will the candidates for the
Master of Science degree in construction
administration please proceed to the
stage we would also like to welcome the
program director Francisco Panetta to
congratulate the graduates weenie wind
cat Raman Shane would Caroline Ortiz or
on Ben Simon Vasily Paco PES William
daen yawning you like my 10:00
Kareem Adam dream Dakar Milosh yo a
bitch
olara romanov senang janae Dennis over a
Pablo for us come on a second
okay
basically Solange okay yeah bad Shankar
gene Arboleda Anna flora read Brian
Vanderhoff
Urvashi Kizuna Raj kiss hoon
Benjamin Suzuki Patrick Leung I'm doing
benefit well the candidates for the
Master of Science degree in enterprise
risk management please proceed to the
stage we would also like to welcome the
program director Sam Siegel to
congratulate the graduates few young you
Paula Bosco
Philip the Tito Dimitri Papa Papa valve
above laughs applause sorry Julie Ann
Marie casino Jessica sighs Xu Tong moon
hi gang Louie K hyung Lee Jae Jin Lee
jung-woo
yang mine yesin yang hai Chien you show
yell Li Shu in the Oh terrine Arif Wang
ji ho run Sheng Wang Kai green Lin Shu
Zheng will the candidates for the Master
of Science degree in information and
knowledge strategy please proceed to the
stage we would also like to welcome the
program director Katrina Parks bomb
Kaylie Dixon takea Anika Ali
Nadira ramratan Rebecca Solomon
Jonathan Lee Jung tae free to stinger
Kenneth Nixon ania see ring John sharp
zooming leave lure Dez Lopez Caroline
Alton burned Joel Ruffin Michael
McCullough Audrey Douglas Pharaoh
jean-philippe Norah Lee Donald
sigh you fun Jean Paula
he's on collapse Margo corn span
[Music]
Karen Isaacson Kelsey w life Christopher
Chandler kiss work Cody Chandler will
the candidates for the Master of Science
degree in narrative medicine please
proceed to the stage
we've also like to welcome the program
director dr. Craig Irvine to
congratulate the graduate the hurry
I'm a Rachel Chun so you assist
Sasha Kruger Naida Hassan's a da sauna
Sasha chug
Ruby Lucia Bellini Madeleine hizzoner
Jason Janeiro Saigon the ick
Sara court
Christina smile Rose Jeremy yang Brandis
Louis Lux Karen yogam well the
candidates for the Master of Science
degree in negotiation and conflict
resolution please proceed to the stage
we would like to also welcome the
program director doc dr. Beth Fisher
ushido to congratulate the graduates
Dominic Rinaldi Samantha Jackson
Karolina took Duque around go Kimberly
low
and Marie Hager Churston Pew Natasha
appeal best fan Philip sons money
Kareem Nikita
Dustin Posner Russell Brand wine
Michelle Arbonne Alex okay low okay low
[Applause]
Shen's nan-zhao Nicole Romero
hey Lindsay
[Music]
William Frick
Derek Kenyan soul
Fabio Hana hey fall Judea
Jessica will see evil Paul James Einar
Larson Deena Raphael marina saga nets
Irene garbage savelii Alexandra first
Guevara Manuel Carroll CC grant Tony say
[Applause]
Courtney and tick tock
Donald Murphy SL karma Nova Rochelle for
10/10 Francis
Justine casita lavas counts Haley count
stringer Angela ammo echo
Koishi su a hero she how young will the
candidates for the Master of Science
degree in nonprofit management please
proceed to the stage we would also like
to welcome the program director
Cyndi lot to congratulate the graduates
Makeba kid rhea yong li wei-ting lien
julia assessory thomas Quigley Karen
Suzanne darling Ashley Lynn June Smith
Susan Marcin Douglas Moore jr. Stephanie
Barnett Jonathan comas
Joan Griffith Lee Madeleine be caught
Emily Poojari chastity Logan Lee and
tongue Gabrielle
Frankel Megan KC Colby Plaskett
Margaretta Lorraine Willemijn Trevor Dom
back
Sarah Azizi Kalia Harrison
Songyi Vanessa
Montano GE Shay Han Sheng Ming you bow
the young woo Fritzi DS on James
Jacob Strang Christina
Hoyas
[Applause]
Terry Peck Rhiannon McClintock Carly
Salman Ashley Amrani
[Applause]
Hilary Stingley Rebecca Smith
Shabri Washington Melissa
Richie
[Music]
will the candidates for the Master
Science degree in sports management
please proceed to the stage we would
also like to welcome the program
director vince Gennaro to congratulate
the graduates Neha Agrawal handsome her
Kelly Carol Brad luck would Steven list
Scott Spencer recent Wang Jonathan
sapphire Andrew Hawkins
Joshua Carol yes Raja tree
Alexander sapega Taylor banks Jeremy
listen Joseph's been CEO Michael
Gallagher in liquor Jason Robert Joshua
De Angelis Elena bank ahsoka
Ciara crews Bradley - yay
Joseph Greenaway
[Music]
Tyrell Ryan Brewer potential Jean Carlos
Rivera
Haslem Toby radio beaming red be balmy a
cash but mission
Marquis wen Hao songs justin pack
[Music]
Meredith McDonald Nikolai Eriksson
Robert Morris Lauren Elizabeth O'Leary
Emily - Marissa tsuneo Angela yang
Olivia
manda Lloyd Gabrielle areas Joseon
Cardosa Rojo Azalea Laden's Isis Gillis
Steven Copa needed
[Applause]
will the candidates for the Master of
Science degree and sustainability
management please proceed to the stage
we would also like to welcome the
program director dr. Stephen Cohen to
congratulate the graduates avanthika
Goswami Jordan Burke khyati Takhar Derek
Noah
Diana Ramos thread young Gaby
Danielle Zender Sophia Buddha Jean
Bergman Teresa sermon when they have
good
Mattia bajpai McKenzie Clark
[Applause]
Amanda Stevens Alyssa what Melissa Meg
Lee ro Scott Neilson clear coming our
Melges VN christopher men GRE dakota
Gangi
Beth Heidi Joshua Wallen grace Lynn Juan
Pablo Padilla so Robert Cornejo Crosby
Alan Jenna
Curtis Morrow zubeida Bentley Sheree
yang kun Shen Shen Karen
Elizabeth Widener Janet Danielle Staub
bill
Catherine Alexis McGee who's V Gregory
beef
Lisa lieberbaum Celine carts road
Rebecca Ruiz Nicole Rose MA
Nadia sir Ianto
[Applause]
[Music]
Melissa Draper gallant Leo for Braga
Nancy Nancy Al Barsha Joshi shin me sir
carita me Odin
Michelle yay
Victoria a Detroit over beshi Jordan
Chan Piper Brighton Arielle kebbel off
Kurt volt
lenka malkov ah Jocelyne gone
Gregory Alcott
Mirotic a key Courtney
Kirsch and a Gifford
Elena's de Oliveira Charmin hak-seon
Rachel fitness
you ate one Molly Smith Eric Li Shan son
Alyssa love Lorena Kruskal Yara Nagi
[Music]
Zachary
Alexis bill Diana true shell david
huggins miles Scott Sarah primero Lisa
Susan Williams sitar cantana a manag one
a guru Sarah young Leticia nervous
Sean Patrick Merryweather pretty Shankar
sighs and Hot Rods Mac Krishnan Joseph
Savior Sargam Seraph
Eliza Cooney Alejandro Perez blah Anna
relic Irina right Vidya Morgan
Beatrice Reyes Lyra Alejandra graves
Ratana Milan Bravo
Clayton Cola
[Music]
[Applause]
will the candidates for the Master of
Science degree in technology management
please proceed to the stage we would
also like to welcome the program
directors dr. Arthur Langer to
congratulate the graduates Jorge
Rodriguez Katie Corcoran Sreenivas
pendulum Arkady Mordecai Joe Ben Caputo
Astra George hakuna room aber asana AJ
money
Kiran Nagi suji's Kumar near mala and
Lauren Goodwin Naga Ronnie to Malala
Martin Rob we shall rue pani mark pop
Elano
Satine Patel
Vantage S Guin drogyn one Australia so
she can't compete sing Eliza Wong Suman
Mishra Manish Shah Nicole Williams
Joseph Dimitri goodness table
Kunal Naik
Arnav bajpai from Joey Ramone Michael
Brumfield Christian Archibald
Marcus Jung Jennifer Sal Christopher
Burke
Robert Fairbanks
Ricky Melendez jr. David Jordan suni
Tasha
Amir Wacha and Sentaro a teeth rub
bonnie has if bite Steve Perry Carlos
Ramos this analyst Allah Gordon Peter
Cole's Elka say babies
areum Cunha watt or a one-game some gay
a bus Mohammed Monica Velasco Caitlyn
Connell
now all marques Lou Engel Scott Shepard
George Garrett hung gangly k7 on Jackie
[Applause]
ah
I don't know about you but my hand hurts
congratulations to the class of 2017 no
no no that wasn't good enough let's try
this one more time
congratulations to the class of 2017
[Applause]
alright alright now that's better that's
better
[Music]
so as we close out this ceremony it's my
it's my sincere hope that you all as
graduates will take advantage of all the
knowledge gathered here and apply it to
become the next generation of
best-in-class professional leaders
remember my five-point call to action
change constantly learn to succeed not
just to cope reinvent yourself be
excellent and engage Columbia
congratulations again to the Columbia
University School of Professional
Studies class of 2017 I invite all of
you this remarkable achievement to
celebrate with your fellow classmates
for a reception following over will be
able to lead you out to the left
thank you again it's my pleasure in my
honor to serve as your Dean
congratulations to you all
[Applause]